in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Doug
and Ashley are here hey guys how are you
hey
welcome welcome good to have you so
you're here to do your debt-free screen
yes we have been planning this trip for
a very long time and where do you live
we live in Broken Arrow Oklahoma is just
right outside of Tulsa Oklahoma gotcha
cool and how much dad of you guys paid
off and just slightly over a hundred and
three thousand dollars excellent how
long did this take roughly five years in
two months making what kind of money um
started out I was single at the time
making about thirty five thousand and
now together we make about seventy five
thousand dollars
excellent what do you guys do for a
living you name it we do it my wife runs
an in-home daycare we also have a
wedding photography business which also
means she also makes cakes for that and
we also do wedding planning and we were
complete entrepreneurs we do everything
we can to help support these wonderful
crazy kids over here ah
and how many wonderful crazy kids have
you got we have five between her me and
together okay all right yours mine and
ours yes very cool and what ages names
Kayleigh she is 11 then Christopher is
10 Ethan is 8 Judah is 7 and Hadley the
youngest is running on air she is 2 ah
and got the cookies going good Dorothy's
cookies are on on sale today for free so
it's good very cool you guys will
congratulation and here so what kind of
debt was the hundred and three thousand
it was a little bit everything we were
completely as normal as you could be
about thirty five thousand was debt
brought in from previous marriages that
we had to pay off and then we had a
couple of cars in there we had credit
cards we I when I was single I financed
my entire life I needed a washer/dryer
new couches new everything you could
imagine so and then some student loans
in there just a little bit of everything
combined so what happened five years ago
that puts you guys on this journey tell
me about tell me your story well
basically five years ago I my ex-wife
and I got divorced and I was a new
single dad with three children and I
realized all of a sudden that I didn't
want to walk 50 steps in my apartment to
the laundry man I had to have a new
washer and dryer so I had to go do that
needed brand new cars
and all that so I came up the first
month realizing that I had premarital
debt and about sixty thousand dollars of
debt and I was working one job and
couldn't pay it so my father had
actually bought us the home study course
Dave Ramsey's home study course and it
was sitting on my shelf because I'm like
I'm not that bad off everybody else's
worse so I started looking at it and I
realized we needed to do something so I
started just going crazy I got a second
job
I was working for twenty two hour days
in a row and then I had my kids the
other three days so I mean about the
first year and a half before I met this
beautiful lady I had paid off about
thirty thousand dollars on my own Wow
then God brought her along he was
sleeping only three hours a day yeah Wow
between two jobs and it was funny
because I actually had somebody one of
my jobs say you know you're in your
early 30s you don't need to work this
hard you just need to enjoy your life
and I was like well I don't enjoy my
life because I can't pay for it so I'll
rest when I'm live like nobody else I
met this beautiful lady and we had met
God brought us together and she brought
her son and then we we started a job
together she started a home date there
because we didn't want to raise our kids
somebody else too and then my passion
was photography and hers was as well so
we started our own business and it's
been a very long journey because we've
done it so slow everybody's told us go
get a business loan and just buy what
you need and advertise and we're like no
because if this goes under we're not
adding it so it's been slowly just
paying cash and reinvesting and just
knocking it out every spare money we
have we just throw at the debt we've I
love our kids because we've gone to
McDonald's once and they're like can we
go to McDonald's and one would be like
are you kidding do you want to be
debt-free know so it's it's been us to
them and them to us so actually when you
guys meet he's already on fire doing
this stuff he was it really wasn't
optional at that point it wasn't and it
was very very hard I came from no budget
at all I mean weird
my ex and I were living paycheck to
paycheck I mean just barely making it
and when we got married it was like jump
right in this is my budget like this is
my grocery budget I think that was the
hardest part for me was just going from
his like minimal eating budget to I'm
used to
cooking you know like just making meals
for the family it's really difficult
just trying to adjust yeah yeah
definitely yeah cool very cool so what
do you tell people because you guys have
been at this all along yeah
tell people the secret to sticking with
it well it's constant communication
there we just weed there sometimes we'd
have an emergency budget meeting twice
in one day because of something that
would need it and you know with kids you
you know there sometimes we have to
throw the budget out and just redo it
because you know again school starts
every August and they need clothes
funnily enough luckily with three boys
we do a lot of passing but hardest part
for us has just been sticking to it when
you get to those I've heard a couple
people on your show when you get to
those big things ticket items like the
car when when all we have left is the
two cars and it's just every single
month just chipping away at that 16,000
or 15,000 just keep doing that it just
seems like we're not winning on the
small things anymore so staying
motivated was a lot for us so yeah
definitely
very cool how does it feel now that
you're there amazing it's great it's
kind of fun because we went and saw
Chris Hogan came to Oklahoma City in
December and we had signed up to go see
him not realizing we were supposed to be
debt-free in April but God blessed us my
grandmother who passed away 13 years ago
I was her executor she had no money she
was living in a retirement home and we
weren't expecting anything and we hear
people all the time say well we got this
inheritance and we're like well that's
great for other people but we're just
you know hashing it out and the state of
Oklahoma called me the Treasury
Department 13 years after she passed
away and said there's unclaimed property
and we're like really so we filed the
claim they wouldn't tell us how much and
it was split between me my brother and
it ended up being $30,000 each oh so we
were gonna come see you in April and be
completely debt-free but because of that
and when we went to see Chris Hogan you
know we didn't even know that
immediately has thrust us into baby
steps for now yes now we've you know the
extra 25,000 and we had to pay off by
April is now baby step three and now
we're going home and calling our ALP for
investing and we're gonna like we're
already there so it was like please God
thirteen years later it was just a
blessing in disguise this I mean our
whole marriage we've been praying every
single day every single night
you know God bring us
you know through the mail through just
different avenues just less us yeah and
we didn't even know I mean there's just
so many things that God has working
before you even know about it and that
was definitely one of them and we were
just super excited and blessed that you
know that we were given the ability to
be debt-free this early because it's
setting its congratulations you guys all
right has the tribe been practicing
we've all the way from all right well
let's get a Cayley Christopher Ethan
Judah and Hadley all gathered up here
and do our debt-free scream Doug and
Ashley in the tribe one hundred and
three thousand dollars paid off over
quite a journey over the last five years
making thirty five up to seventy five
count it down let's hear a debt-free
screen all right guys you ready here we
go
three two one
that's a family tree changed right there
stuff has changed permanently there well
done you guys hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of Wall Street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality you're
not a victim of racism you're not a
victim